(Latin acoustic guitar)
- Today I'm transforming into one
of Peru's most famous
huayno singers, Dina Paucar.
One of El Salvador's most
celebrated artists, Tono Salazar.
- I'll be playing Evita Peron.
I think just growing up, she was always
like this icon that women looked up to.
She was fighting for labor rights,
feminism before that
was really a movement,
she had a charity and a foundation.
- He would make caricatures of people
who were just dicks in history,
kind of do commentary through his artwork.
He was sassy with his artwork,
and I'm a little sassy with my words.
- I grew up listening to Dina Paucar.
My grandfather would play
it all the time in the car,
her music has impacted me so much,
because it reminds me
so much of my grandpa.
Every time I listen to it,
I just get so emotional.
- She was an icon, very powerful,
and I'm very proud to tell my family
that I got to play Evita Peron.
- My hair's such a big
part of my identity,
I felt like a different person.
- My grandpa would have loved
to have seen me transformed into Dina.
- He was kind of pushing
for rights for all people,
like I'm doing that in my own way now.
I feel a sort of connection to him.
- She wasn't afraid to dream,
and she let her music speak for herself.
Her music is just so soulful,
and it really just makes
you feel something.
- It feels like she's almost
this mythological being,
which is why I think she
still has so much impact
even years after her death.
- It was really cool to like
channel my Peruvian roots.
(Peruvian guitar and flute music)
She has a Cinderella story.
She was cleaning homes, she was
selling food on the streets,
she always had her dream of singing,
and she was so passionate about it.
- Seeing the set, and
even seeing the things,
like the tools and the paint,
I just was imagining, what was life like?
What was it like to be this
creative person back then,
and to be making political
statements through your art work.
(chill Latin guitar and percussion)
- I think someone like Evita
is always someone to remember by.
(bandonion tango music)
You know, we're trying to picture her
in her most passionate time,
which was when she was giving
speeches to the people.
She was very big with her arms,
she had very big arm movements.
(bandonion tango music)
Really great experience, you know,
remembering what she stood for
and learning more about her.
I'm definitely proud to be Argentinian.
- It was just exciting to
shine a little bit of light
on somebody who represents
my country in the best way.
- She was a very proud Peruvian woman,
who's killin' it, and I'm just so proud
to be able to transform into her today.
(Latin acoustic guitar and percussion)